bonjour je me présente barèges marie
sabrina j'habite au port j'ai 28 ans je
recherche je travaille dans le domaine
du secrétariat
si possible dans le s ou dans le nord
j'ai un bep comptabilité et bien le
titre d'agent administratif
j'ai aussi fait un pré qualif de mètres
du secrétariat assistante commerciale
j'ai trois pôles dans le domaine du
secrétariat dans la dans le domaine de
la comptabilité et dans le domaine de la
pente dans le domaine du secrétariat de
la comptabilité
j'ai fait un stage dans un collège et
aussi dans un centre social et culturel
au port et aussi dans le domaine de la
vente
j'ai travaillé dans un magasin je suis
quelqu'un de très sérieuses dynamique
que motivé je sais travailler en équipe
et même autonome cima contagieux vous
plaît n'hésitez pas à me contacter à
cette adresse